الاقرار الضمني بالخساره لم ياتي اقل الى
من صور الدمار التي تشحت بها ضخمه بعد
اكثر من 200 يوم من هذا القتال الشرس رئيس
الاوكراني
حاصر وجود المدينه التي تبلغ مساحتها 41
كيلومترا بقلوب الاوكرانيين بقوله بخنط هي
اليوم في قلوبنا فقط وضفنا ضخمه اصبحت
مدمره بالكامل لا مباني مشيده صامده في
المدينه الا القليل وفق تعبيره
اعتقد اننا فقدنا سيطره على مدينه باغفورت
لكن عليكم ان تفهموا انها تحولت الى لا
شيء الروس دمروها بالكامل لا يوجد فيها
بناء الامر ماساوي اليوم بامكاننا القول
ان باخموت فقط في قلوبنا لا يوجد شيء هناك
الا الدمار والكثير من القتل الروس الذين
اتوا الينا
الامال الاوكرانيه الضيقه التي تمللت
بينما تبقى في بخمت من جدران سقطت هي
الاخرى فالمدينه انتقلت من ايديو اوكرانيا
الى يد روسيا وفق ما اعلنه على الاقل رئيس
روسيا
هن قواته بالسيطره على مدينه
يعود الى الحقبه السوفيتيه ارتياموفيسك
حيث قائد فاجنرغيني وبخلفيه لا تتعدى تسعه
جنود حاملين على مي روسيا وفاغنير اعلن
الانتصار في المعركه التي استمرت 224 يوما
اكد بريجوجن ان قوتي ستبدا الانسحاب من
المدينه المدمره اعتبارا من يوم الخميس
مسلما بذلك اول انتصار بارز لبوتين في
اوكرانيا كما وعد اذا اشهر من المعارك
الداميه جاءت بتكلفه كبيره على الطرفين من
حيث العديد والعتاد فيما المدينه اضحت
حطاما فمعركه بخموت خسرت فيها فاجنر الاف
المقاتلين معظمهم من المدنيين الذين جندوا
من السجون الروسيه هذه الخساره وان صحت
ستمثل جائزه نيوتن رغم عدم اهميه المدينه
استراتيجيا فجائزه سيكافئ فيها فعليا كل
جندي تميز في هذه المعركه وسيقلده وسام
شرف استحقه وفق قوله
[موسيقى]
الفك الروسي اطبق على مدينه ضخمه الواقعه
الشرقي اوكرانيا واستمات في الحصول عليها
رغم اهميتها الاستراتيجيه القليله مفرمه
اللحم وصف لم ياتي من عدم فخسائر باهظه
ومؤلمه المت بالطرفين لاسيما روسيا وفاجنر
لتطرح تساؤلات كثيره عن استحقاق هذه
المدينه للثمن المدفوع اهميه ضخمه
الاستراتيجيه ضئيله ومتواضعه لكنها اطحت
رمزا معنويا للطرفين فبالنسبه لموسكو
وتحقيق تقدم او نص وان كان متواضعا هو
بالغ الاهميه في هذه المرحله بعد ان امضت
قوتها اشهرا بمحاوله اسقاط المدينه دون
جدوى قبل التدخل فاجنر وتحولها لراس حرب
هناك كما نسيطر على بخمه وفق اعتقاد الروس
قد تخولهم تقدم اكثر في دنيتك وسيطر على
هذه المنطقه الاوكرانيه الشرقيه لكن
الاهميه الكبرى للقبض على ضخمه تتمثل في
ضرب معنويات الق الاوكرانيه وحتى توجيه
رساله للغرب باستمرار المكاسب رغم الدعم
العسكري الجبار الكيف وفق ما تقوله ديلي
تيليجراف غير ان رسائل روسيا كلفتها باهضه
في ضخمه وفي محيطها تمثل بمقتل ما بين 20
الى 30 الف روسي وفق تقديرات غربيه
واستخباراتيه رغم تفادي الدفاع الروسيه
الاعلان عن خسائرها البشريه الكلفه
العسكريه لم تكن اقل ثمنا من حيث العتاد
والاسلحه المدمره اما المدينه الخاليه من
سكانها البالغ عددهم ثلاثه 73 الفا فهي
مدمره بالكامل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات